- Waitresses can be fired
for gaining more than
7% of their original
body weight.
- Overweight women
earn small paychecks
than average size women.
- That's right, that's right.
You're momma's so
fat she suffers from
systemic bias in
a job market that
marginalizes her just
based on her appearance.
Oh!
(audience laughing and clapping)
- My worse thing, we
going to be hungry.
That was the worst
feeling in the world.
That was devastating.
You know, when you
go to be hungry,
it's just like, it's
a nightmare. You know.
And you have these dreams
that you eating stuff,
waking up, your pillow gone.
You know.
- If there was a pill
that you could take, okay.
That would mean
you could get out
of your wheelchair for good,
but it would mean
that you would be
irreversibly obese for
the rest of your life,
would you take it?
- Oh, ah. No.
- [Larry] Keep it 100.
- No, I wouldn't, because
I don't know where
I'd get all my comedy from
cause my parents love me, so.
- Hey America,
Larry Wilmore here.
If you like The Nightly
Show on Comedy Central,
like us on Facebook too.
Just don't poke me, I
do not like being poked.
You can Candy Crush me.